[Musik]
barocke fassaden treffen auf moderne
architektur
nach acht jahren bauzeit ist die
neuinterpretation des historischen
barockschlosses in der mitte berlins so
gut wie fertig außen und innen treffen
überall alt und neu zusammen
beherbergt hier zukünftig das
humboldtforum ein neuer ort für kultur
und wissenschaft
das humboldtforum ist kein schloss der
support forum ist ein radikaler neubau
der so hat es der bundestag beschlossen
aber anders alte berliner schloss
erinnert in dem draußen an drei fassaden
und auch hier in dem zentralen hof die
fassaden des vorgängerbaus genau
rekonstruiert worden sind sogar original
teile des alten schlosses sind in den
neubau integriert
vor der schrittweisen eröffnung glänzt
erst einmal die reine architektur und
die erzählt deutsche geschichte seine
barocke fassade erhält das schloss im
achtzehnten jahrhundert im zweiten
weltkrieg stark beschädigt lässt es die
ddr-führung 1950 sprengen
an seiner stelle entsteht der palast der
republik sitzt der ddr-volkskammer 1989
die ddr bürger schaffen ihr eigenes
regime ab 2006 wird der palast der
republik abgerissen nach vielen debatten
2012 beginnt der bau der
neuinterpretation des schlosses die
kosten 677 millionen euro teilweise
finanziert durch spenden die geschichte
des ortes soll auch in den geplanten
ausstellungen beleuchtet werden und
vieles mehr
es geht natürlich auch um die großen
themen die die sammlungen der
ethnologischen museen hier mit ins haus
bringen es geht um kolonialismus zum
colonia lied es geht um die gebrüder
humboldt es geht um wirklich eine
globale perspektive von heute auch auf
den historischen zusammenhang den dieses
haus hier abbildet hier wurde die
architektur des neubaus andacht im
norditalienischen vicenza architekt
franco stella gewann 2008 den wettbewerb
zum schlossbau
die wichtigsten straßen plätze und
bauten des historischen zentrum berlin
waren auf das los bezogen mit der
rekonstruktion werden diese beziehungen
wieder erlebbar
[Musik]
die korona pandemie verhindert die jetzt
eigentlich geplante festliche teile
eröffnung des schlosses berliner und
berlin besucher können sich aber bereits
an der außenansicht erfreuen
wir könnten loslegen und bitter ist es
dass wir das ohne publikum machen müssen
also diesen meilenstein begehen denn es
ist ja ein haus für uns alle für
menschen aus aller welt und wir hoffen
dass bald denn auch wirklich das
publikum her kommt denn für die machen
wir das
[Musik]
das neue alte berliner schloss ein
bauwerk mit geschichte und einer
barocken fassade hinter der sich viel
modernes verwirrt
[Musik]